hello and welcome to the new world
review your cells for everything anime
and manga and today it's hunter hunts
time again and this time around we're
going to go through all of the Guardian
n beasts currently being used by the
princes involved in the succession war
now this video has come about as a
result of my recent succession war recap
or I did go on to explain the concept of
guardian beasts but elected not to go
into them into too much detail because
it would have further bogged down and
already incredibly detailed every video
but a lot of you were interested in each
individual beast which is why we're here
today so as part of the succession
contest which is intended to be a battle
to the death to choose the sole
surviving legitimate Prince to become
the future ruler of the cockin Empire
each Prince made an offering of a drop
of blood into an item known as the sea
done this is a nan construct conjured by
the very first king of Cockaigne who
proceeded to use it as a device to have
his children fight in the very first
succession contest after completing the
ceremony each participant is fed an egg
by a fairy like creature which they
cannot see due to the nature of nan and
that egg eventually spawns a parasitic
type nan beast now given that most of
the princes are not natural nan users
the actual nan conjured crafts these
constructs is sourced by the nan left by
deceased members of Carkoon royalty who
wished for the offspring to prosper
however once in existence than n beast
is sustained by the aura of the person
it is attached to which goes on to
influence every aspect of the beast
including its shape its nature and of
course its power also just like nan in
general these beasts offer an infinitely
versatile range of outcomes to perfectly
suit their hosts however unlike most
uses of nan the princes themselves can't
directly control their beasts due to
them being conjured from the nan of
another in fact the princess cannot even
see then and beasts all the base of
other participants of the wall even if
they are proficient end-users which
implies that one of the conditions to
activate this power is this blindness
for the duration of the contest or that
there is another specific condition to
fulfill before one can see either their
own beast or the beasts of others quite
notably though this rule does not apply
to outside and end users any nan wielder
not involved as a participant in the
succession contests can see each of the
beasts perfectly fine once the beasts
have taken on a physical form anyway of
which there is actually one base it
doesn't have a natural physical form but
we'll get to that and it's also
important to note that the current
cocoon ruler can also see the beasts
although that may be due to them having
fulfilled a required condition
speaking of let's begin our exploration
of these guardian beasts with King
nasibi who still maintains the Beast he
used in his succession war and while its
abilities are unknown it does certainly
reflect NASA bees interest in
with various formations of female body
parts and a general animalistic nature
but moving on to the current war we have
the Beast of 1st Prince Benjamin sadly
another beast we don't know a lot about
at the moment but it would appear to be
heavily based in the realm of
physicality with a variety of natural
weapons at its disposal as well as
absurdly chunky legs
it also contains quite an insectoid form
with beetle wings as well as what would
appear to be a mass of small eyes on its
well I guess we'll call it a face but it
reflects Benjamin pretty perfectly as he
is an incredibly aggressive individual
who embodies the ideals of a soldier
focused on strength and domination
stepping onwards to second Prince
Camilla her guardian beast is much more
abstract in nature although certainly
not the most abstract we'll be examining
here today but its form essentially
follows that of a sea anemone with a bit
of flair around its lower portion
resembling the skirting of a grand
address so you know a bit of style and
flair combined with a deep sea creature
representing Camilla's outwardly public
nature of elegance versus her private
deeply sadistic and heartless persona
Camilla's beast as it would seem with ol
Guardian beasts is also an independent
ninh user itself and its natural
affinity is that of a manipulator which
is able to take control of people once
certain conditions have been met the
beast will then go on to grant this
control to the will of camilla herself
making it a pretty dangerous being and i
should also say now that camilla is an
exceptional nen user in her own right
and has developed at least one hot sue
known as the cat who has lived a million
lives and very importantly this is not
to be confused with a guardian beast
rather this is a form of post mortem nen
which activates once Camille has been
killed absorbing the life force of the
murderer and reviving camilla from death
so as I'm sure you can see Camilla's nan
beast has the potential to be pretty
damn broken in combination with her
existing ability as in theory she could
force someone to kill her via the
manipulation of the Beast and then have
that person automatically die as a
result of her and postmortem net scary
stuff moving out to 3rd Prince Angley
and his beast is probably the one that
personally fascinates me the most
it's a mysteriously flat entity and a
conjurer that produces a coin from its
mouth every day it has been speculated
by Zhang Lee himself that these coins
are not meant to be kept for himself but
rather to be given out to trusted
subordinates and contain abilities that
are activated upon the fulfillment of
certain conditions sangli also
hypothesized that these coins would not
be immediately beneficial to his part in
the succession war thinking that their
true power would only come to fruition
once they had been spread on master
the kingdom after he had taken the
throne which is a very very long term
goal considering that only one coin is
produced per day however the coins do
appear to appreciate in value over time
as a coin with a number one on it later
upgraded itself to a number 10 and so
another thought that was brought up by a
bodyguard who was aware of this ability
was that the purpose of these coins may
be to exchange them for a power of the
equivalent value by reinserting them
back into the mouth of the nen Beast in
question although said bodyguard deemed
it too risky to try that for himself
onwards to everyone's favorite 4th
Prince to ratnik India we may have
another confusing one because Surat Nick
currently has two nan beasts however
only one of these was created by the
cedar in ceremony which is the one that
looks like a horse with very selectively
feminine features like most guardian
beasts it appears to be capable of
phasing through physical substances as
well as having the ability to detect and
neutralize hostile aura sources but its
primary power has to do with surrounding
himself who eyes rather blatantly stated
that the thing he hates most in this
world is a lying wench as such if an
individual they may or may not have to
be a wench biasness radnik these beasts
will scratch them with its bob tongue
then the next time that person lies the
Beast will issue a verbal warning but
the third time they lied to Surat neck
they will cease to exist as a human now
as for what happens if an individual
does engage in this serve I well we
don't know as of right now but it has
been speculated that they will be
transformed into some sort of being to
serve as a pawn to the prince while
we're here let's not ignore sûreté neck
southern investor which was the result
of his specialist affinity at the moment
it is thought that this beast may be the
key to sir anacs peril of future hatsue
which allows him to briefly invoke
recognition whilst in a state of zetsu
and the reasoning for this connection is
that engaging in this ability provides
Surat Nick with a future vision from the
perspective of this nen beast however it
does get slightly more complicated
because in theory forcing oneself into a
state of zetsu would despawn any nan
constructs including the Beast and balsa
radnyx based gained from the seed own
ritual does disappear and so in theory
so should the second once born directly
from him the standard rules of nen are
unfortunately more or less thrown out
the window
due to Sarai next specialist nature so
we're just gonna have to wait for more
info on that one in the meantime let's
get back to some basics with 5th Prince
to Peppa no guardian beasts has one of
them on basic science resembling a spiky
spiky toad which can allegedly
synthesize various drugs and chemical
compounds within its own body via
transmutation very fitting as to Peppa
is heavily invested in
however there is a further condition
placed upon this beast as it has been
referred to as a coexisting type and
requires a partner to engage in its
ability kind of like a research
colleague tipep is beast is also one of
the more cautious constructs in the
succession war as it chooses not to
appear at all in the presence of first
Prince Benjamin soldiers or as every
other guardian beast we've examined thus
far this had no such issue being present
for all capable of seeing them to do so
six Prince Tyson's beast takes the form
of a floating angelic eyeball of love
this beast is an emitter type that seems
to spawn small cycloptic creatures with
slender slender bodies who then attach
themselves to whatever individual
listens to the teachings of Tyson at
this point I should say that Tyson is a
wild optimist who genuinely believes
that love alone can change the world and
as opposed to violent actions of any
form to this end she has become
something of a cult influence and hernán
beast assists that aspect by absorbing
aura from those listening to her
teachings and bestowing them with a
feeling of happiness in exchange not
only that but this feeling is made more
potent in direct correlation to how
thoroughly one has read the book of
Tyson yes the book of Tyson exists thus
perpetuating the strong religious
connection those followers have with
Tyson this isn't awkward news though
because all religions have fairly strict
doctrines of some kind and Tyson's is no
exception so as a result should the one
and only taboo of Tyson's teachings be
broken then hernán beast will deliver
harsh punishment to the sinner in
question as for what that taboo is we
currently don't know next up we have
seventh Prince loser is's beast and it
is a gigantic centipede like thing which
focuses on conjuration quite
specifically it is designed to lay traps
by conjuring whatever particular target
desires and then activating an ability
once that person has fallen victim to
the quote-unquote trap a very vague
ability to examine here and not
immediately easy to see how it connects
to loser us himself
because we know such little about him at
face value though he does seem to be a
pretty decent guy but the fact that his
beast has taken on more of a
bait-and-switch idea may give us a
glimpse of his true nature
8th Prince Alice Alice beast essentially
takes on the form of a coughing with
disturbingly human lips and as is
natural when considering prints Alice
Allah its powers are tied directly to
his libido essentially the Beast
periodically admits smoke from its
various mouths covering a radius of
seven meters on average the inhalation
of this smoke then allows the beast to
manipulate the affected persons into
thinking more favorably of salus Allah
and not
that after a certain amount of smoke has
been inhaled a small clone of the nen
beast will appear above that person's
head and emit smoke had a two meter
radius essentially turning them into
carriers who could go forth and convert
others into thinking of silo silo
favorably the rate of conversion depends
entirely on how the person inhaling the
smoke feels about silo seller to begin
with that so for example an already
devout follower of the prince would be
affected within eight hours or so while
someone on the complete opposite end of
the spectrum with no favourable thoughts
of Solace Allah will eventually succumb
but it will take 70 hours to do so also
very notably we should point out that
Salas Allah takes no responsibility
fears life whatsoever and has his mother
do everything for him and that is also
reflected in his nan beast who as a
result has no way of defending itself
ninth Prince Haakon Berg's beast is the
first enhanced type we've encountered
here today taking on the form of a furry
one-eyed gargoyle thing this mighty
beast can imprint opinion on to the back
of hulking Berg's as well as his
bodyguards left palms and with the
exception of the prince upon receiving
the pinion the targets are knocked out
and upon awakening they've had their
memories of being knocked out erased and
to those who are not loyal to Hulkenberg
the pinion vanishes after ten minutes
however for those who are loyal to or
kannberg the pinion remains and the mall
people acquired in this manner results
in a substantial growth in or output
amongst all those branded by it due to
this increase in power in direct
correlation to will in loyalty it is
also thought that holcomb bugs and n
beasts may have been the one to grant
him his heart suit possession error as
it developed immediately after
Hulkenberg made a strong resolution to
win the succession war 10th prince cat
chose beast is the first one with an
actual name and it is called without you
well it despite the fact that it does
have a name it doesn't actually have a
natural physical form so it also happens
to be the most abstract beast not
managing to obtain a form until a
certain condition was met which was the
death of either culture or her twin
sister forget sue upon the death of
either of the sisters without you will
take the form of the deceased and
protect the remaining system and in the
case of the series without you assumed
the fall of Cacho after it was
discovered that trying to escape the
succession war would result in immediate
death and currently without you resides
with forget sue and catch those guys
speaking of 11th prince forgets who's
based is also tied directly to her twin
sister and takes the form of an
inanimate object being a door the door
is identical to the entrance of a
playground in which Cacho and forgets
who played in his children and has the
power to immediately take forget sue to
wherever Cacho
although once she steps out to find
Cacho only Cointreau can open what is
known as the return door which can take
the sisters seemingly to any destination
they wish so in this case it's very
handy that without you exist to continue
to assume the form of Karcher after her
death as the use of return door is still
possible as a result 12th Prince mama
says guardian beast is one of the more
adorable ones with a dark twist it is a
manipulate type that more or less
wanders around and asked various targets
if they are free if photograph' eyes
that know they are not free then a
little replica of the Beast will appear
on their shoulder and continue to ask if
they are free until an affirmative
answer is received but as soon as the
individual replies that they are free
this nen beast will take control of
their mind by inserting what can only be
described as a small teddy bear spider
thing into their ear and then generally
it will force them to slaughter whoever
is around them something to note is that
the teddy bear spiders do not sustain
themselves from Mama's Ozora but instead
the aura of the target in question
meaning that they will vanish if they
become unable to access the targets aura
through whatever means this beast also
comes with some pretty major
restrictions the first of which being
that it can only target an end users as
those unfamiliar with nan will be unable
to see or hear the Beast and secondly
Mama's ax is only able to take control
of a single person at a time
the stress of which will drain her
stamina to the point where she needs to
sleep immediately afterwards which also
results in dispelling the nen Beast due
to not having mimosas or it feed off
leaving her absurdly vulnerable getting
to the end now I promise and we have
13th Prince Mario is beast which
resembles a Chinese dragon but its eyes
and general appearance seems to change
according to Mario's mood and while it
isn't currently confirmed it is highly
suspected that this known beast is the
one responsible for erecting a barrier
around barham's room which allows people
to exit the room but not to enter in
fact should a person attempt to enter
Mario's room they will instead be
transported to an alternate empty room
and to finish things off we have 14th
prince wubble who as of right now is the
early prince whose nan beast has not
made an appearance in the series and
therefore they cannot tell you anything
about it but that pretty much does it
for this breakdown of the guardian n
beasts currently being wielded in the
succession war I hope this in
combination with my other video has
helped or refreshed her investment in
the manga and makes it easier to dive
back in whenever we come back from
hiatus if you enjoyed this video and the
content this channel produced in general
then please do consider donating to the
new ultra via patreon because the
support of all of your amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
plot this channel an incredible amount
and if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to my
discord server or a wide array of
shenanigan ori takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on the Guardian in beasts
this has been the new walter view and
i'll see you next time